c'est un sport qui mélange handball et
water-polo le tous pratiquants à bord
d'un kayak le kayak polo se joue à cinq
contre cinq sur l'eau un match se divise
en deux mi temps de dix minutes
le principe mettre plus de points que
l'équipe adverse dans un but situé en
hauteur c'est du kayak alors faut savoir
faire du bateau et après dès qu'on prend
la balle en main on oublie le bateau
donc si on n'est pas bon en kayak à la
base on n'arrive pas très bien à
manoeuvrer et ensuite après c'est un
véritable sport collectif
on est obligé de mettre en place des
tactiques des techniques pour pour pour
jouer comme dans tous les sports
collectifs de petits terrains pour
savoir où on est où son nouveau
coéquipier et savoir où on va surtout
pour aller vers le but et marqué les
gens qui sont plutôt attirés c'est les
familles les amis ont à dire les gens
qui passent parce que ils sont jamais vu
cette activité une journée du
championnat régional de ce sport se
déroulait à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines l'occasion de faire
connaître aux curieux cette discipline
encore méconnue
ça commence à se développer de plus en
plus surtout grâce aux jeux olympiques
les personnes se rapproche beaucoup de
des clubs de kayak
après découvre des activités comme le
kayak polo qui n'est pas diffusée à la
télévision
attrapons pratiquer le kayak polo depuis
15 ans le club compte aujourd'hui une
centaine de licenciés